first on cbs morning's eve rodsky joins
us now uh eve thank you very much for
being here uh the documentary is very
good and very dangerous uh if you
haven't had conversations about dividing
the chores you will watching this but
before people can solve a problem
they've got to recognize that there is a
problem and i think one of the great
eye-opening moments and anecdotes in the
documentary is the story you tell about
going to lunch or trying to go to lunch
with four or five women
and all of you get bombarded by spouses
significant others elsewhere saying
where is this i need that what did that
moment reveal to you no no there's a
question tony where one of the husbands
asked does do the kids need to have
lunch
yeah they need to eat those kind of
questions today yes
what are that thank you
thank you for having me
um well that was my first act of
resistance uh tony because
uh for me
i had this was 11 years ago i started to
study these issues but nobody was
talking about it when people said you
know what do women have to complain
about you're graduating from college
more than
and then men
uh you're you're you're taking up
leadership positions and workplaces but
what i saw is that equality has to start
in the home
and it started with those texts i
counted up every single text and phone
call we had received we had 30 phone
calls
and 46 texts
for 10 women over 30 minutes
and then the amazing thing is when men
are asked how much they do to contribute
to taking on the household chores and
the child care they overestimate
and women actually underestimate but
when you after that meeting uh or after
that eye opening moment made a huge list
of the blankety blank stuff i do uh it
really brought it home so in the time we
have rather than detail the problem
because a lot of people watching are
like yup that's my household how do you
solve it how do you get the household in
order and more equal
well i think the first thing is bringing
attention to it
so
we know
from research that
people do not really think about their
home as an organization
um as one wonderful man said to me
he said my home is the type of place
where you wait to decide who's taking
the dog out
right when it's about to take a pee on
the rug
and so what this documentary is trying
to do this film is trying to show that
when you bring
structured decision making which often
people don't associate with the home
which only means people are afraid of
that term it just means you know who's
doing what in advance
that leads to the end of bias because we
know the end of bias
is when you leave assumptions at the
door
you know i thought it was so interesting
jennifer siebel newsom who's a great
filmmaker also was involved very heavily
she wrote produced directed i'm very
familiar with her work and i think that
this should be required viewing for all
couples married whether you have kids or
don't have kids it is so so so good and
one of the things you all included was
uh couples from the lgbtq community
which is often not something you see why
did you decide to do that and what did
you learn
well i think
a lot of our problems gail
uh when it comes to
chores housework um finally getting to a
quality in the workplace actually start
from our home and there's a lot to learn
about other family structures
and what we saw especially with lgbtqia
families was that
so many of those couples had had to have
difficult conversations
yeah early in their marriage or before
their marriage whether it's about coming
out adopting a child and so when you can
start having really difficult
conversations early you continue to have
difficult conversations and really this
movie is a love letter to communication
yeah just to say systems are important
but communication is important
thank you big problem big movie fair
play out now